KATE FLINT: Thank you
all so much for coming.
And thank you to
Google for inviting me.
It is a real treat to be
here, let me tell you.
All photography requires light.
But the sudden intrusive light
of flash photography is unique.
It's quite unlike
the illumination
that comes from the sun or
even from artificial lighting.
"Flash!"
is the first book to
tell the history of flash
and its effects and
associations in a way that
links it to the broader
history of photography.
And I'm interested
in it in particular,
because flash photography
breaks down familiar categories
and hierarchies, since
it's used across the board.
It's used for fine artwork.
It's used for news photography.
It's used for amateur snapshots.
It's been used to reveal
shocking social conditions.
It puts on display the
most overlooked corners
of everyday life.
Paparazzi chase
celebrities with flash.
Large public events and
intimate family occasions
are captured through flash.
Flash is used to record and
detect crime and its aftermath.
What's more, flash is used not
just to illuminate darkness
but also, so to
speak, to stop time.
It allows one to photograph
really rapidly moving objects,
like the ball of
ice cream that's
being flipped into a milkshake.
So in the book I ask, what is it
that makes flash photography so
distinctive?
And I think, too, about
flash's associations,
like the connection
of flash with memory.
I do things like
tracing the origin
of the cinematic flashback.
And I think about the concepts
of flash drives or flashbulb
memories.
So this history is
about several things.
It's about a piece of
technological apparatus--
or rather, successive
pieces of apparatus
that are used to provide
enough illumination to take
an effective photograph
in a particular place,
at a particular time, when
there wouldn't otherwise
be enough light to do so.
It's concerned, too, with the
practice of flash photography
and the uses to
which it's been put.
And more provocatively,
it's about light itself
and its relationship to time.
So I ask questions like,
how long is a flash?
And then what happens if
a flash is too bright?
Can one have too much light, as
with the biggest flash of all,
that of the atomic bomb?
So in a moment, I'm
going to elaborate
on four specific features.
And I want to locate
them in various phases
of flash photography's history.
I want to think about the
sense of astonishment and awe
that it originally evoked.
I want to think about that
capacity to stop time.
I want to think
about flash's ability
to light up dark places,
to break into darkness.
And I want to think, too,
about flash's associations
with violence and aggressiveness
and invasiveness and intrusion.
And then I'm going
to wind up by looking
at the work of some
contemporary photographers whose
experimentation rescues flash
photography from the bad press
that it's increasingly received
during the 20th and 21st
century.
But first, a little
bit of history.
So the history of
flash goes right back
to the early days
of photography when
people needed more
light than was provided
by sunlight or daylight.
And they tried to use,
first of all, limelight
and then brightly
burning magnesium
to provide illumination.
And I think that this is
the very first photograph
to be taken by flash.
It was taken using
limelight in 1839.
It's actually a
daguerreotype of a fossil.
But it was so hit and miss
for a number of decades.
In most circumstances, limelight
produced really over-bleached
images.
Magnesium was somewhat better.
It was burnt as wire to
take pictures of caves.
It was blown in powder
form through a flame.
It certainly produced
better images.
But until extraction became
cheaper in the 1880s,
magnesium was not
just expensive,
but it was somewhat unreliable.
And then, all importantly, in
1887 a compound flash powder
was invented by a couple
of German chemists.
And this could be exploded
in so-called flash guns.
Early ones even looked
like a very crude pistol.
It could be ignited on a tray.
It was available for
do-it-yourself mixing.
It was supplied on
impregnated sheets.
Or it was made into
little explosive devices,
rather like tea bags.
And then the flashbulb,
pioneered in the late 1920s,
coming into more general
use around 1930--
its ease, its
portability, completely
transformed news journalism.
The earliest cheap
cameras with synchronized
flash date from around 1940.
And then, after
World War II, a line
stretches from
little flash bulbs
to flash cubes to the
electronic flash that's
now a built-in part of
most consumer cameras.
And then there's also that
bright burst of LED light
that one finds on cellphones.
These developments overlapped.
And there are many
variants to be found
within flash's technology.
What remains linked, and
what remains constant,
though, is the linking of flash
photography in advice manuals,
in specialist publications, in
advertising with the modern--
indeed, with the flashy.
There's a great TV ad from the
1960s that goes, "It's new.
It's now.
It's flash cube," together
with some very Dave Clark
Five-style music and linking
flash to the dance floor
and to the swinging '60s.
And then you see here, on the
right, how Sylvania flashbulb
publicity even offered the
homemaker, for $3 and a coupon,
a foam rubber Sylvania
pop art pillow.
You can make your home swing
now for practically no money
at all.
You, too, can have a
picture of a flashbulb
there in your living room.
And yes, I found one
on eBay, and I do.
OK.
Before I go onto those four
categories I was talking about,
I want to make an
important point.
And it's one that has excited
me in conceptual terms
throughout my research.
And that point is
that flash photography
is a practice that overturns
some of what we think
that we know about photography.
Because in flash
photography, the exposure
is based on the very brief
flaring of an intense light.
It's not you take
a picture and it's
like a freezing of
a moment of time
in a continuity that's
going on both sides of it.
You create the light yourself
with flash photographs.
They're not based on the opening
and closing of a shutter,
according to the strength of
a continuously available light
source.
Rather, flash causes
that sudden interruption.
It breaks into the darkness.
It's human made.
What's more, if, as
can so easily happen
in flash photography, the flash
gets reflected onto a window
pane or a polished
surface, one's
really directly reminded of
the artifice and the technology
involved in the illumination.
And we see this, too, when
as here, the brightness
of the flash results in part
of the plate or film being
flooded with light.
And we see here, even, the hand
of the photographer setting off
that flash in its tray.
And occasionally, too, other
forms of flash apparatus
appear, as there, in
John Collier's photograph
of a family in
northern New Mexico.
When it's so obvious, as
it is in these photographs,
that a flash has been
used, we can no longer
believe in the fiction that
somehow the lens of the camera
operates as the
photographer's eye.
Indeed, at the very moment of
taking the flash photograph,
the photographer, if
she's close to her camera,
is going to have her
vision momentarily blinded
just as dramatically and
uncomfortably as her subject.
So the eruption of
flash disorients subject
and photographer alike.
And that's something that's
used to really great effect,
of course, near the end of
Hitchcock's "Rear Window,"
where the effect
is really something
like seeing the flash from
inside your own eyeball.
So let's look in more detail at
four central features of flash
photography, starting with the
shockingly bright explosion
of light itself and its capacity
for creating astonishment.
Flashes of light
have for a long time
been associated with sudden
inspiration and clarity.
Think about the revelation
of St. Paul on the road
to Damascus.
And in the early decades
of flash photography,
some of its practitioners
appropriated this sense
of quasi-divine
revelation, especially
if they were using
flash to expose
deplorable social conditions.
Jacob Riis, for example, working
as an investigative journalist
in New York in the
late 1880s, saw himself
as he took up this
new technology
as providing illumination.
And the transcendental
overtones of his vocabulary
helped to underscore its
significance as an instrument
of intervention and purgation.
"I hate darkness and dirt
anywhere and naturally want
to let in the light," he said.
In the early decades
of flash photography,
commentators looked for
appropriate language
in which to write about it.
If a theologically-based
vocabulary
suited some of its
ends, if occasionally it
was called "bottled sunlight,"
the most pervasive metaphor
used to describe flash was
the phenomenon of lightning.
Because lightning
shocks, startles,
interrupts the moment--
or creates it, rather, in a
sudden instant of illumination,
rendering everything around
it preternaturally clear
by contrast to the
surrounding darkness.
Lightning was commonly
used in romantic art
and writing-- you know,
think of Frankenstein--
to invoke awe, grandeur,
the sublime, the unknowable,
or even being shocked
by some sudden light.
Looking to borrow
the connotations
of this electrical energy, Adolf
Miethe and Johannes Gaedicke,
who invented the first
flash powder in 1887,
called it Blitzlichtpulver,
or lightning light powder.
And lightning bolts,
as at the bottom,
as here, long continued to
feature in the advertising
of flash bulbs and cameras.
And indeed, there's probably
one of those bolts signifying
a flash feature on your
cell phone right now.
The artificial flash and
the flash of lightning
seem superficially really close.
Indeed, they are
compressed and amalgamated
in this deliberately brief
poem by Bill Knott, "Flash."
In its entirety, it
flares up and reads,
"Photographs--
lightningbolts which,
their shadows having caught
up with them, perish."
But in fact, lightning
and the photographic flash
are very different.
Lightning is unpredictable.
It's uncontrollable in its
occurrence and its location.
When you represent
lightning, almost always
it means being at some
kind of distance from it.
Flash photography doesn't
give us any such distance.
It's often quite
literally in your face.
In other words,
flash doesn't live up
to those awe-inspiring
expectations set up
for it through a
comparison with lightning.
And above all,
that's because it's
the product of human agency.
But exploring the
differences between the two I
found really productive.
Because it's helped
me understand
what is distinctive about
flash as a technological form
of illumination.
It also brings home
that long-lasting desire
to make grandiose claims for
the almost defined properties
of technology, even
as technology here
is coupled with the
innovative and the modern.
And being coupled
with the innovative
leads us to the whole
idea of stopping time.
Because the technology of
flash is about speed as well as
about light.
The word flash is commonly
used, as you know,
in all kinds of contexts--
not necessarily visual ones--
to indicate the extremely
short or the transitory
or the spontaneous, as in flash
mobs and flash floods and flash
fiction.
The two meanings of the
words signifying speed,
signifying light, converge
in high speed photography.
Photographic pioneer
Fox Talbot in 1851
was the first to patent
the use of a spark
to capture a moving object.
That was an experiment
said to have been suggested
by how lightning flash at night
seems to freeze drops of rain
or freeze the water
playing in a fountain
so it looks stationary.
Unfortunately, there's
only verbal, no visual,
evidence for this.
We have to wait until the
work of Arthur Worthington
in the late 19th century.
He showed us what
a splash really
looks like by using
electrical spark photography.
Then, most notably,
there are all
the really beautiful pictures
produced by Harold Edgerton
in the mid 20th century.
And Edgerton's
high speed images,
made by very high speed bursts
of light from electrically
controlled neon tubes, created
the illusion of stopped motion.
Whether he's showing milk drops
falling or bullets piercing
playing cards or
bananas or balloons
or whether he's showing golfers
or tennis players swinging
at balls, these are
photographs that
break down the distinctions
between science and art.
And they reveal far
more than is ever
available to the human eye.
They're a really
powerful manifestation
of what Walter Benjamin called
"the optical unconscious."
High speed flash's
techniques continue
to be used by
photographers to create
eye-catching, arresting effects.
Japanese photographer
Shinichi Maruyma, for example,
has produced these images by
throwing water, here, or ink
into the air and then capturing
the forms as they fall.
Ori Gersht's work simultaneously
references old master paintings
and Harold Edgerton
when, for example, he
shows a bullet exploding
a freeze-dried pomegranate
into an airy bowl of shards.
Hiroshi Sugimoto's
theaters series,
consisting of long
exposure photographs taken
in cinemas which produce an
image of a plain, extremely
bright white light
on the screen,
is, in some ways, though,
the antithesis of flash.
He actually has his lens
open for two or more hours,
the length of the movie.
And the end result is this
really stunningly bright
blank rectangle.
It's a composite image.
It's a record of the
many, many flashes that
go to make up the motion
picture, certainly
in pre-digital form.
It's a film distilled
into a flash.
What's more, as
Sugimoto puts it,
this is not simply white light.
He calls it the result
of too much information.
And I think that this last
phrase can be seen as a rebuff
to the speed with
which we're invited
to view, to experience, to
consume, not just a film,
but culture in general,
life in general.
Sugimoto is saying we're not
given enough time to reflect.
There are too many
continual demands
on our attention, made by
the rapid interruptions
of technological modernity.
Flash photography's
relationship to time
has always been a
really double-edged one.
It allows one to see
the beauties of a moment
that we couldn't
ever visually process
without mechanical aids.
But it's also being
continually associated,
especially in the second half
of the 20th century and beyond,
with a kind of here
today, gone tomorrow
speediness of superficial
consumer culture.
Somehow, flash photography
still is hung around
with all of those
associations with flashiness
and superficiality.
But flash, obviously enough,
is extraordinarily useful.
And let's think about
what happens when it's
used to light up dark places.
I've already talked
about Jacob Riis's desire
for the social and
illumination and transformation
that he thought flash
photography could bring about.
And this is something
that he shared
with other documentarians
like Lewis Hine,
or like one of the
earliest American woman
photojournalists,
Jessie Tarbox Beals, who
exposed both the
despair of poverty
and the drive towards
respectability
that she witnessed in the
tenements of Newark, New
Jersey.
Flash, in other words, has been
indispensable to the practice
of documentary.
It's in relation to
documentary that we encounter
most starkly its most singular
and its most contradictory
aspects--
on the one hand, its
impetus towards revelation
and its capacity
to render visible
what we would otherwise
never see, and on the other,
its associations with
unwelcome intrusion.
Documentary work
brings out, as well,
a further notable characteristic
of flash photography--
and that's its impetus
towards the democratic,
the way in which
it gives emphasis
to all the elements
of an interior.
Because especially in the early
decades of its use in the 1890s
the 1900s, it really couldn't
be carefully controlled.
So many details very
often take on a kind
of unplanned prominence.
A sudden flare of light
reveals with clarity
each dent on a kitchen
utensil, each photograph
on a mantle shelf,
or each image hanging
or pasted on the walls--
each cherished
ornament, each piece
of polished furniture, or
stained and scuffed floor,
or domestic cat, or
marble fireplace,
each accumulation of dust, each
shiny button, each wrinkle.
Flash can bring something
out of obscurity.
It can reveal
details never fully
visible to those who experience
them on a daily basis.
And this giving
prominence to objects
and apparently kind
of random assemblage
is one major way in
flash's usefulness
is invoked for so-called
visual anthropology.
Visual anthropology is a term
pioneered by the Farm Security
photographer John
Collier, seen here
flaring his flash onto a
dressing table of objects
in a Pueblo home, where you see
both traditional bits of Pueblo
ceremonial materials and
family photographs and a very
modern alarm clock and a little
figurine of a horse and a whip
on the right hand side--
all kinds of things.
The detail that flash gives
us can deepen our knowledge
of the material environment
and of the lives of those
who live there.
And I think that much of the
fascination of early flash
photography, of the images
that I've just shown you,
come precisely from
this privileged access
to the lives of others.
Flash, as well as
being responsible
for a violent
interruption, allowed
for the preservation
and representation
of the ordinary--
of what Jacques
Ranciere in his thesis,
really beautifully
terms "the apprehension
of the inexhaustible historicity
found at every street corner,
in every skin fold, and
at every moment of time."
Flash, that is to
say, is associated,
not just with that rapid
explosion of light,
but with enabling
and encouraging
a form of attentive
looking turned upon very
everyday surroundings.
Now the invention
of the flash bulb
made documenting
interiors even easier.
This is something
that we see reflected
in the archives of the Farm
Security Administration.
We've just seen a
couple of examples
in the early 1930s
and early 1940s.
It also gave more control.
While flash readily makes
visible every last stain,
smudge, and scratch,
it can also work
to emphasize cleanliness
and respectability.
Some of the FSA
photographers, though,
were really reluctant
to use flash.
And this brings us to
the last of the areas
that I want to
consider, and that's
flash's association with
violence, aggression,
and invasiveness.
Because it's really fair
to ask, what, if anything,
might justify flash's unexpected
intrusion into daily lives,
especially if you don't know
the photographer already.
Among the FSA photographers,
Dorothea Lange, for example,
saw its use as really invasive.
Ben Shahn had some doubts,
both about photographing
someone else's private
space, but also
about flash's very aesthetic.
"When some of the people came
in and began to use flash,"
he said--
and he's looking back
to the late 1930s--
"I thought it was immoral.
You know, you come into
a sharecropper's cabin
and it's dark.
But a flash destroyed
that darkness.
It's true that a
flash would actually
illuminate the comic
papers that they
used to paste on their walls."
But what met to the biggest
impact on him, he said,
was not actually the
poverty that walls papered
like this revealed, but
something far less tangible,
something that, in fact,
was far less easy to record.
"It was," he said, "the
darkness, the glistening
of eyes, the
glistening of a brass
ornament on top of a big bed.
You know, a glass, a mirror,
that would catch light.
Now, that's a matter
of personal judgment
about this thing, whether
you divulge everything
as a flash would do, or whether
things are kept mysterious
as they are viewed."
This refusal to use flash was
in part a question of ethics.
But it was also in part a
desire to grant darkness
its own mysterious qualities.
It was also, for many
mid-century photographers,
a desire just to use
so-called available light
as a matter of purity and
a matter of distinguishing
themselves as art photographers
from news photographers
or commercial photographers.
Cartier-Bresson, in particular,
[SIGHS] wanted "no photographs
taken with the
aid of flashlight,
if only out of respect
for the actual light--
even where there
is not any of it."
He said, that to use
flash is "impolite,
like coming to a concert
with a pistol in your hand."
The African American
Roy DeCarava
said, "I don't try
and alter light,
which is why I never use flash.
I hate it with a
passion, because it
obliterates what I saw."
Of course, the introduction
of the flashbulb
had greatly enhanced the
ability of press photographers
to work at night.
And so it consolidated the
association of flash newspaper
photographers and
the documentation
of crimes committed under
the cover of darkness.
Flash was increasingly
used by police forces,
by journalists, even by
detectives for recording crimes
and criminals.
And it inspired detective
fiction and film.
I really recommend George
Harmon Coxe's Flash Casey,
and less recommend the TV
series, "Man With a Camera"
from the 1950s, largely
because it is so obviously
a vehicle, a commercial vehicle,
for Sylvania flashbulbs.
It's a huge plug for
them-- so much so that
the star, Charles Bronson,
he complained really grumpily
that, "by the 10th
week I realized
I was playing second
banana to a flashbulb."
But nobody more famously
brought flash and crime together
than Weegee.
recording murders,
accidents, arrests.
His self-publicity was
completely synonymous
with his Graflex Speed
Graphic camera and its flash
synchronizer, to the extent
that he once montaged himself
into a flashbulb.
Even Weegee, though, despite
his reliance on the flashgun,
expressed some ambiguity
about its powers.
And the frontispiece to his
1945 photo book, "Naked City,"
suggests through
visual irony that he
knew it was possible to stand
back from flash's illumination,
and acknowledge a potentially
more sublime electrical force.
I think this is a
really atypical moment
of humility on Weegee's part.
Overall, his work added to
that growing association
of the flash with aggression
and intrusiveness,
especially in the
hands of the rapacious
and sensation-seeking
news photographer.
And nowhere has this
determined intrusiveness
been more apparent than
in the work of paparazzi.
The popping of flashbulbs
has become visual shorthand
for the achievement
of fame or notoriety.
And this firing off,
a barrage of light,
can be a terrifying onslaught.
Think of King Kong
brought to New York City,
exhibited on stage, and then
startled into destructive rage
by the flashes of
newspaper photographers.
Paparazzi flash has come to
equal unwelcome exposure.
And paparazzi themselves
really work as a stand
in for the worst excesses
of the exploitative,
the invasive photographer,
caring for nothing
other than hunting
down the shot.
So flash photographers have
come to take on a bad name.
In my conclusion, I'm
going to really ask,
can flash photography
be redeemed?
Flash photography is no
longer awe-inspiring.
Indeed, it still can
disturb us today--
and largely, I guess,
because we experience it
as invading our private
space, hurting our eyes,
breaking into whatever
we might be looking at,
or thinking about.
By and large, photographic
flash has lost its novelty.
It's certainly lost all
association it might ever
have had to the sublime.
It's now a finely-tuned means
of creating and controlling
light--
not just illuminating darkness
but providing fill flash
or, as Martin Parr does,
intensifying color.
But however pragmatic
this might be,
it's very much been at the
expense of an aesthetics that
emphasizes the surprising,
the unpredictable,
and the revelatory.
But in contemporary
photography, flash
has recently come to take
on a strong self-referential
presence.
And often this calls
attention to one or more
of the major themes
that I've talked about--
illumination, speed,
violence, paparazzi.
And sometimes, photographers
try to recapture
some of its early properties,
showing that it can still
captivate and astound.
Flash illumination
registers most obviously
when the photographer
deliberately calls attention
to the artifice that they're
employing, as here, not least
by calling the image "Flash."
Or in Maya Dickerhof's
image, "Family,"
from a series which
is called "Memory."
And this is an image that riffs
off amateur mistakes-- getting
too close with the
flash, bleaching out
what it is that you really
want to take the photograph of,
the family grouping
in the middle.
Via its title, though--
or the title of the
series, "Memory"--
it speaks to how difficult it
can be to recollect a moment
except through a photograph,
because that bleaching
light stands for time's passage,
the fading, obliterating
effects of memory that
family photography
so desperately tries to deny.
Or a quite different
[INAUDIBLE] paparazzi work
is appropriated by Cindy Sherman
in "Untitled Film Still #54."
And so here she is caught
in flash's sudden glare
with her expression
somewhere between
surreptitious and angry--
sort of somewhere between
Marilyn Monroe and Princess Di.
Or consider the series by German
artist Viktoria Binschtok,
"Flash."
In pale greys and
whites, her images
show very faintly,
barely discernible,
a celebrity actor
walking through a crush
of photographers
entering their car.
And I think the point
that she is making
is that both image
and celebrity may
be said to be overexposed
through flash.
This intense
bleaching, of course,
recalls flash's
largest and most deadly
form, one that I showed earlier,
the flash of the nuclear bomb--
the extreme point reached
by flashes that accompany
potentially lethal activity.
The close relationship of flash
photography to actual weaponry
is explicitly referenced in
British photographer Sarah
Pickering's "Celestial
Objects" series.
Unlike Harold Edgerton, who
uses the strobe light to turn
the flight of a bullet into a
disconcerting thing of beauty
rather than a display
of force, Pickering
opens up her camera's
shutter and photographs
a bullet fired from a
revolver in the complete dark.
All the light comes from
the explosion itself.
In her use of darkness and
flame, the blur of light
and the white hot core
of gunpowder's ignition,
she returns flash photography to
the unpredictable and thrilling
category of the sublime.
And the raw power of
electrical discharge,
too, is still being
used by photographers.
Floris Neususs made his
Nachtbilder, his night photos,
by leaving sheets of
photographic paper
out at night in thunderstorms
so that they carry the imprint
of exposures made by lightning.
And Hiroshi Sugimoto's
"Lightning Fields" project
deliberately harks
back to earlier
technological experimentation,
like Etienne Leopold
Trouvelot's studies of sparks.
As well, too, through its
title, "Lightning Fields,"
evoking the potential for
natural sublimity inherent
in Walter de Maria's New
Mexican installation.
As with Neususs'
work, no camera is
involved in Sugimoto's
"Lightning Fields."
He introduced a Van de Graaff
generator into his studio,
capturing on film its 400,000
volt electrical charges.
The end results look
a bit like streaks
of lightning branching
off, root-like,
from an incandescent
spinal core.
Or they look like trees.
Or they looked like Edward
Weston's cabbage leaf.
They look like bleached
trunks and leaves and branches
in a pitch dark landscape, or
like forms of primeval life
turning and sending
out fern-like tendrils
of new growth in swirling water.
So in the cultural history
of flash photography
that I've been
outlining, we see how
it's been useful for
practical ends, how
it's been useful in journalism,
and in fine art work.
To be sure, flash is often
irritating or invasive.
And in the book, I show
how these associations
of interruption
and of irritation
are taken up in
literature and in film.
But as Sugimoto's
"Lightning Fields" suggests,
the imaginative
photographer can still
turn sudden and surprising
light to thought-provoking ends.
Despite the bad press that
flash photography has received--
and I would argue, plenty
of times really quite
justifiably--
despite the bad press
that it's received
over the century and a
half since its invention,
something of its
original sense of wonder
may still, very
effectively, be reclaimed.
Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you very much.
We do have time for questions.
Please raise your hand
if you have a question.
I can start with one
whilst you're thinking.
So my question
would be, it seems
quite unusual to specifically
talk about flash photography.
What got you interested
in this subject?
KATE FLINT: I was--
OK, I've got a background
in both literature
and in art history.
And I've written quite a lot
about Victorian visuality
and visual cultures.
And I was deeply aware that I
haven't ever written very much
about photography.
And so I started a project
which was about language
and photography, and the
kind of language that people
use to write about
photographic images,
and the taking of images,
and the representation
of photographers
within literary texts--
that kind of thing.
But I'm also a photographer.
And I was-- and I showed
one of my pictures
earlier of lightning striking
over some hills in New Mexico.
And I was just
thinking, wow, it's
hard, unless you're
taking a video,
to take photographs
of lightning.
And then I thought, huh.
I mean, you wouldn't use
flash to take a lightning
photo at night.
But I wonder if people ever
brought lightning and flash
together.
And so yes, the tool was Google.
I went off and thought,
lightning, flash, photography.
And I turned up
so many references
in the 19th century
in particular
that I started to write
a lecture about that.
I had to give a lecture
at a conference on light.
And it's like so often
with projects, you
start off with
something that you
think might be a chapter
or even half a chapter.
And before you know where you've
gone, you've found out so much,
and you've gotten
so excited about it,
that it's just mushroomed
into an entire project.
So that was how it got going.
I think that this--
I mean, I'm intrigued that I,
myself, very, very, very rarely
use flash as a photographer.
And I don't know if there are
photographers among you here
who want to claim, yes,
I use it all the time.
I'll do anything
other than use flash,
except for fill
photography in daylight.
But I felt I
learned a lot more--
felt I'd gotten a
lot more respect
for the aesthetics of flash
through writing this book.
And so that was a really kind of
great but surprising byproduct
for me.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
This talk, it's amazing.
As a continuation,
actually, from what you said
and from your
question, do you think
there is room, a good place
for flash photography,
in today's society,
given that it
is considered intrusive,
aggressive, quite violent.
Where do you think flash
could be better used?
KATE FLINT: I think
sometimes it's
just going to be necessary
because you are somewhere
where you can't bring
in studio lights.
But I think that,
firstly, the improvement
of digital photography and
the speed of digital chips
means that a lot
of the time, you
don't need flash nearly
as much as you used to,
just even for
taking a photograph,
an ordinary photograph,
in a room like this.
You wouldn't even think,
probably, about using flash.
I'm much more
intrigued by somebody--
I mean Martin Parr is
the most obvious example
I can think of--
who does use flash
in daylight and uses
it to make color pop
out just a bit more.
And now, he knows he could make
that color pop with Photoshop.
But he still prefers
to use flash.
But he's not using
a flash attachment
like most of us would use
on a camera, or, you know,
holding a flash gun at the side.
He actually uses a ring flash,
which was developed for taking
photographs in your
mouth at the dentist's.
And so that doesn't
show a big shadow.
It was used a lot for fashion
photography in the 1980s.
There was a whole--
there's an amazing kind of
cover of "Vogue" with Linda
Evangelista, herself holding
up a kind of a flash gun
photograph using ring flash.
And I think that that
is an example of sort
of experimentation with
the lighting technique
that happens to be
flash but happens
to be the right technique
for Parr for the effects
that he is trying to create.
But I do wonder whether the
current photographic interest
or an interest that's been
going on maybe 10, 15 years
and saying, let's use a
photograph to think about flash
and to think about the
effects that it creates,
whether they're good
or bad, has something
to do with a kind of a
diminishing use of it
except, in particular,
by paparazzi, by news
photographers, and suchlike.
Though, of course, ever
since the allegations,
which seem not to
be true at all,
but it was a flash
going off being
fired into Princess Diana's car
that caused that car to crash.
That kind of urban
legend is one of many
that has really consolidated the
totally bad rap that flash has.
So people then play
and riff on that.
Yes, I think I saw
your hand first.
AUDIENCE: So you actually
just mentioned the bad rap
that flash has.
And I guess to some degree,
it may be warranted,
especially if it's
used badly like it
might be by amateur
photographers that might--
especially the on-camera flash.
Like, I always have to--
I'm sure that you
feel the same--
but I always have to
cringe when people, well,
quite obviously use their
camera in automatic mode.
And then the pop-up
flash pops up
and then they take a
night photo outside
and use the flash for that,
or they take an indoor photo
and completely ruin the
image because that's what
the pop-up flash normally does.
Do you think there's
a need for more
education around good
and bad uses of flash?
And how could we go about this?
KATE FLINT: One of
the things I totally
loved about writing the
book was immersing myself
for a while in photo
manuals, going back
to the 19th century and all the
way through the 20th century
and into the 21st.
And of course, now there is
masses of online information
about how to use flash, how to
take a good flash photograph,
all the pitfalls
not to fall into.
So I honestly think it's
one of those areas in which,
if people want to have
even rudimentary education,
that they can find out.
And I suppose a certain
amount of education
then comes in a sideways
way when you see photographs
that say no flash allowed here.
And then you think,
well why not?
So no flash allowed here
might be at a sporting event.
You're in an arena and flash
might just catch a player's eye
and distract.
Or you're told in
a wildlife refuge
that you can't use flash
at all because if you're
taking pictures into a
dark bush or at night,
then that really would
have a disruptive
effect on the animals there.
The whole question
about whether or not
you should or shouldn't
use flash in museums
is one which has really
exercised museum curators.
Because probably even with
multiple, multiple uses
of flash, there's very little
these days since flashbulbs
going off isn't going to
happen anymore-- you know,
they're not going to get their
canvases spiked with those.
So is it about copyright?
Is it about disrupting
the viewing experience?
Is it just sort of traditional?
We don't use flash in a museum.
But I think it provokes people
to say, well, why can't we
use flash here, even at a
kind of subliminal level.
So I guess there's some kind
of education going on there.
I think what really gets me is
when I see people using flash
at a concert, say.
And you just see all these--
you know, light all over.
And that's great for
a cinematographer who
wants to get some kind of a
sense of, I am at a concert.
But this has been turned,
that kind of phenomenon,
to amazing use by this New
York-based group called Improv
Everywhere, which
some of you will know
for doing these
sort of great, let's
freeze for five minutes
in Grand Central Station.
So everybody-- you
know, normal people.
"Normal people."
Everyday people walking
through Grand Central
are going, uh, what's
happening here?
But they had an experiment, an
improv, where they asked people
to turn up with
their cell phones,
with their point and shoot
cameras and their flashes
and all let them off at the
same time from Brooklyn Bridge.
And photographs
are taken of this.
And of course it was entirely
and utterly ineffectual.
So it was one of those
sort of demonstrations
of both a communal event
showing that flash, perhaps,
doesn't do all that much.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
When did photographers
really start
to want to control the output
and application of their flash
using things like bounce
and diffusers and umbrellas
and all of that kind of stuff?
And was it a long time
after they'd already
realized how unflattering
the full-on flash effect is?
KATE FLINT: That's
a great question.
And it is one that--
I would say once you have
that compound flash powder,
in particular-- so, post 1887--
manuals and
photographic magazines
continue to be
full of instruction
about how you can bounce flash
off a curtain at the side,
or how you can use a
newspaper that is held up,
or how you can position
flash in particular places
within your
fireplace, or how you
can hang a gauze
curtain over a window
and let off flash behind it.
And so one of those things
that is compelling to me
about the photo manuals
of the late 19th
and the early 20th century
is how inventive, you know,
so-called amateur
photographers were.
If you were a
professional photographer,
if you had a studio,
you could afford
some of those readymade
screens and hoods and devices
that were advertised
for use with flash.
On the other hand, if you're
a really well-to-do poncey
photographer with a
studio, you probably
had electric lighting
by that stage,
but that's another question.
But the amateur photographer
was forever swapping stories
about, hey, maybe you could use
this, maybe you could use that.
And so really, the whole
history of photography
has been asking, how
do we control light.
How do we use either natural
light or artificial light,
however it's produced, to
create the particular, either
practical effects or aesthetic
effects, that we want?
So the answer is,
that experimentation
has been going on
ever since people
were using artificial lighting.
SPEAKER 1: We would
have time for one more
question if anyone has one.
If not-- one
question over there.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Hi.
KATE FLINT: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I wonder how
you think about the future
of photography--
if you're kind of in line with
the technological developments.
It would be interesting,
your opinion.
Thank you.
KATE FLINT: So the
question's about how
I see the technological future
of photography and flash.
And I think a lot
there I would take back
to what I was saying about
speed with digital photography.
I mean, how fast,
how sensitive, can
we make digital chips in terms
of their reaction to light.
Is flash going to seem like
something which, you know,
is some strange,
quaint old technology?
Are we going to talk about
flash photography in retro terms
at some point?
I think we probably do that
already in some quarters.
But I also think that it's like
one of those questions which
is completely
unanswerable, because it's
going to be the more exciting
photographers and artists
and installation artists,
and perhaps particularly
installation artists
like Eliasson
who will use flash as
part of an installation.
That show on light that was
at the Serpentine a while
back had some terrific
examples of what
one could call flash
light, but used
not to record a
photographic image
so much as to give the viewer a
certain kind of experience when
they were themselves
at an installation,
getting them to think
about what light can do.
So it's going to continue
to be used in photography.
But the imaginative ends
to which it is put--
I guess we will have to say,
well, what do we want to do?
What do we want to show?
And how do we want
people to think
about light, and
the power of light,
and in what ways do we calibrate
between light's controlability
and its unpredictability.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you very
much, Professor Kate Flint.
KATE FLINT: Thank you.